ya es el tercer incendio más grande en
la historia de california
dixie ha calcinado 175 mil hectáreas con
fuegos que no cesan desde el 14 de julio
es decir un área mayor al tamaño de
nueva york' y ha arrasado con la pequeña
ciudad de green view
mis oraciones están con todos y es en
todo el condado quiero decir green bay
es solo el comienzo de todo además ha
obligado a más de 16.000 personas a
evacuar esta semana y varios están
desaparecidos a pesar de que miles de
bomberos trabajan cada día para
extinguir los incendios
solamente han logrado contenerlos en un
35 por ciento y quiero agradecerles
mucho por hacer su trabajo y salir y
tratar de controlar esto y deseo deseo
que termine para ellos también y no los
cinco incendios más grandes de la
historia de california han ocurrido en
los últimos tres años una frecuencia
aterradora